Y eso me puso en contacto
con voluntarios y ayudantes.
Por ejemplo, cuando estudiaba en la escuela de posgrado
en la Universidad de Queen en Canadá,
los presos de la cárcel de Bahía Collins aceptaron ayudarme.
Les di una grabadora, y leyeron en ella.
Como uno de ellos me dijo:
"Ron, no iremos a ningún lado por el momento".
(Risas)
Pero piensen en eso. Esos hombres,
que no habían tenido las oportunidades de educación que yo había tenido,
me ayudaron a ganar títulos de postgrado en derecho
por su dedicada ayuda.
Bueno, volví y me convertí en un académico
en la Universidad Monash de Melbourne,
y por esos 25 años,
las grabadoras eran todo para mí.
De hecho, en mi oficina en 1990,
tenía 29 km de cinta.
Estudiantes, familiares y amigos me leyeron el material.
La señora Lois Doery,
a quien más tarde llamé mi madre sustituta,
me leyó muchas miles de horas en cinta.
Una de las razones por las que accedí a dar esta charla hoy
fue que estaba esperando que Lois estuviera aquí
así poder presentárselas y agradecerle públicamente.
Pero, lamentablemente, su salud no le ha permitido venir hoy.
Pero te doy las gracias aquí, Lois, desde esta plataforma.
(Aplausos)
Vi mi primer computadora Apple en 1984,
y me dije a mí mismo,
"Esto tiene una pantalla de vidrio, no sirve de mucho para mí".
¡Qué equivocado estaba!
En 1987, en el mes que nuestro hijo mayor Gerard nació,
conseguí mi primer ordenador ciego,
y de hecho está aquí.
¿Lo ven aquí arriba?
Y ven que no tiene, ¿cómo llaman a eso?, ninguna pantalla.
(Risas)
Es una computadora ciega.
Es una Keynote Gold de 84k,
y 84k significa que tenía 84 kilobytes de memoria.
(Risas)
No se rían, me costó 4000 dólares en ese tiempo. (Risas)
Creo que hay más memoria en mi reloj.
Fue inventado por Russell Smith, un inventor apasionado
en Nueva Zelanda que estaba tratando de ayudar a las personas ciegas.
Tristemente, murió en un accidente de avioneta en 2005,
pero su recuerdo sigue vivo en mi corazón.
Significaba que, por primera vez,
podría volver a leer lo que había escrito en ella.
Tenía un sintetizador de voz.
Había escrito como coautor mi primer libro de derecho laboral
en una máquina de escribir en 1979, solo a partir de la memoria.
Esto ahora me permitió leer de nuevo lo que había escrito
y entrar en el mundo de la informática,
incluso con sus 84K de memoria.
En 1974, el gran Ray Kurzweil, el inventor estadounidense,
trabajó en la construcción de una máquina que escanear libros
y leerlos en voz sintética.
Unidades de reconocimiento óptico de caracteres a continuación
que solo operaban normalmente con un tipo de letra,
pero mediante el uso de dispositivos de escáneres planos de carga acoplada
y los sintetizadores de voz,
desarrolló una máquina que podía leer cualquier fuente.
Y su máquina, que era tan grande como una lavadora,
fue lanzada el 13 de enero de 1976.
Vi mi primera Kurzweil comercial disponible en el mercado
en marzo de 1989 y me dejó sin aliento,
y en septiembre de 1989,
el mes que mi cargo como profesor asociado
en la Universidad de Monash se anunció,
la escuela de derecho obtuvo uno, y yo podría usarlo.
Por primera vez, pude leer lo que quería leer
poniendo un libro en el escáner.
¡No tenía que ser amable con la gente!
(Risas)
Ya no sería censurado.
Por ejemplo, yo era muy tímido en ese entonces,
y aún sigo siéndolo, para pedirle a alguien
que me lea en voz alta material de sexo explícito.
(Risas)
Pero, ya saben, podía sacar un libro en medio de la noche, y...
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Ahora, el lector Kurzweil es simplemente
un programa en mi laptop.
Eso es a lo que se redujo.
Y ahora puedo escanear la última novela
y no esperar conseguirla en librerías de libros parlantes.
Puedo estar al día con mis amigos.
Hay muchas personas que me han ayudado en mi vida,
y muchas que no he conocido.
Uno de ellos es otro inventor estadounidense, Ted Henter.
Ted era un piloto de motos,
pero en 1978 tuvo un accidente en coche y perdió la vista,
lo que es devastador si estás tratando de montar motos.
Luego se convirtió en esquiador acuático
y fue campeón en ski acuático para discapacitados.
Pero en 1989, se unió a Bill Joyce
para desarrollar un programa que leyera
lo que estaba en la pantalla del ordenador
de la red o desde lo que estaba en el equipo.
Se llama JAWS (acceso al empleo con el habla),
y suena como esto.
(JAWS hablando)
Ron McCallum: ¿No es lento?
(Risas)
Ven, si leo así, me quedo dormido.
Bajé la velocidad para Uds.
Voy a pedir que lo reproduzcan a la velocidad que lo leo.
¿Podemos ponerlo?
(JAWS hablando)
(Risas)
RM: Ya saben, cuando están corrigiendo ensayos de estudiantes,
desean pasarlos con bastante rapidez.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Esta tecnología que me fascinó en 1987
ahora está en mi iPhone y en el de Uds. también.
Pero, ya saben, encuentro que leer con máquinas es
un proceso muy solitario.
Yo crecí con la familia, los amigos, leyéndome,
y amé el calor y la respiración
y la cercanía de la gente leyendo.
¿No les encanta que les lean?
Uno de mis recuerdos más perdurables
es en 1999, Mary leyéndonos a mí y a los chicos
cerca de la playa de Manly
"Harry Potter y la Piedra Filosofal".
¿No es un gran libro?
Todavía me encanta estar cerca de alguien leyéndome.
Pero no renunciaré a la tecnología,
porque me ha permitido llevar una gran vida.
Por supuesto, los libros hablados para ciegos
son antecesores a toda esta tecnología.
Después de todo, fue desarrollado el disco de larga duración
a principios de 1930,
y ahora estamos poniendo libros hablados en CDs
usando el sistema de acceso digital conocido como DAISY.
Pero cuando estoy leyendo con voces sintéticas,
me encanta llegar a casa y leer una novela mordaz
con una voz real.
Ahora todavía hay barreras
frente a nosotros, las personas con discapacidad.
Muchos sitios web no podemos leerlos utilizando JAWS
y las otras tecnologías.
Los sitios web son a menudo muy visuales,
y tienen toda esa clase de gráficos
que no están etiquetados y botones que no están etiquetados,
y por eso el Consorcio 3 World Wide Web,
conocido como W3C, ha desarrollado estándares en todo el mundo
para Internet.
Y queremos que todos los usuarios de Internet o propietarios de sitios de Internet
hagan sus sitios compatibles para que
nosotros, las personas sin visión, podamos jugar al mismo nivel.
Hay otros obstáculos provocados por nuestras leyes.
Por ejemplo, Australia,
al igual que cerca de un tercio de los países del mundo,
tiene excepciones de derecho de autor que permiten que los libros se traduzcan en braille
o lectura para nosotros los ciegos.
Pero los libros no pueden viajar a través de las fronteras.
Por ejemplo, en España, hay 100 mil
libros accesibles en español.
En Argentina, hay 50 mil.
En ningún otro país de América Latina
hay más de un par de miles.
Pero no es legal transportar los libros
desde España a Latinoamérica.
Hay cientos de miles de libros accesibles
en EE. UU., Inglaterra, Canadá, Australia, etc.,
pero no pueden ser transportados a los 60 países
en nuestro mundo donde el Inglés es la primera y la segunda lengua.
Y recuerden que les hablé sobre Harry Potter.
Bueno, como no podemos transportar los libros a través de las fronteras,
debían tener versiones diferentes de lectura
en los diferentes países de habla inglesa:
Inglaterra, EE. UU., Canadá, Australia,
y Nueva Zelanda, todos deben tener
lecturas separadas de Harry Potter.
Y eso es por lo que, el mes próximo en Marruecos,
tendrá lugar un encuentro entre todos los países.
Es algo por lo que un grupo de países
y la Unión Mundial de Ciegos están abogando,
un tratado transfronterizo
por lo que si los libros están disponibles bajo una excepción de copyright
y el otro país tiene una excepción al derecho de autor,
podemos transportar los libros a través de las fronteras
y dar vida a la gente, especialmente en los países en desarrollo,
a personas ciegas que no tienen libros para leer.
Yo quiero que eso suceda.
(Aplausos)
Mi vida ha sido extraordinariamente bendecida
con el matrimonio e hijos
y ciertamente un interesante trabajo para hacer,
ya sea en la Universidad de Derecho de Sydney,
donde serví un período como decano,
o ahora que me siento en el Comité de las Naciones Unidas
sobre los Derechos de las Personas con Discapacidad, en Ginebra.
De hecho he sido un hombre muy afortunado.
Me pregunto qué nos depara el futuro.
La tecnología avanzará aún más,
pero todavía puedo recordar a mi madre diciendo, hace 60 años,
"Recuerda, querido,
nunca serás capaz de leer la letra con los dedos".
Estoy tan contento de que la interacción entre los transcriptores de braille,
los lectores voluntarios y los inventores apasionados,
ha permitido que este sueño de la lectura se haga realidad para mí
y para las personas ciegas en todo el mundo.
Me gustaría dar las gracias a mi investigadora Hannah Martin,
que es quién me pasa las diapositivas, que avanza las diapositivas,
y mi esposa, la Profesora Mary Crock, que es la luz de mi vida,
que viene a recogerme.
Quiero agradecerle a ella también.
Pienso que tengo que decir adiós ahora.
Dios los bendiga. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
¡Oye! (Aplausos)
Bien. Bien. Bien. Bien. Bien. (Aplausos)